I'm going to cover several techniques
that can help improve the look of your
procedural terrain specifically we'll
talk about more advanced blending
techniques try planar mapping splatting
and texture repetition we're continuing
the series on 3d world generation in
this project and talking a bit about
texturing strategies there's a reason
the big AAA games go to real lengths to
get the terrain looking good it's a
complex subject and there's a lot of
ways to do this we previously covered
quadtrees and planetary level of detail
but up until this point we sort of
skirted the issue of textures and
shaders on the train in favor of mesh
generation what I'm going to do today is
cover a few different approaches to
terrain texturing a sort of
mix-and-match of techniques that you can
be familiar with and you can decide
whether or not they're right for your
project
so those techniques are tri planar
mapping texture splatting height based
blending and texture repetition and what
I'm going to do is go over each of these
in a bit of detail remember that the
code is all available as well if you
need to reference it feel free let's
start with tri planar mapping so let's
look at what this technique is trying to
fix we've got some simple rolling hills
and we choose the UVs based on the XY
coordinates so once I add a texture it
all looks textured now if I were to
sharply increase the height of the
terrain say for a cliff face or
something like that notice what happens
you've got this ugly stretching right
here on the cliff face and that's
because we're essentially projecting a
texture down from above and this is
exactly the problem we're looking to
solve we want that texture to be applied
appropriately from every angle not just
above this is where try planar mapping
comes in the idea behind it is really
simple sample the texture three times
once along each axis and then projected
onto your geometry along that axis and
just kind of blend based on which way
it's facing going back to this piece of
the landscape now if you were to sample
the texture now not just from above but
from each side and then blend them all
together this would look a lot better
let's take a quick look at the shader
code that makes this happen what I do
here is I use the world space position
of
each fragment and then we take the
normal here and use this as the waiting
for each texture sample one thing I do
need to call out try planar mapping for
the diffuse is really easy but it's a
little trickier to get the lighting
right and that's because you need to
construct your tangent properly then
golus has a nice write-up that I'll
include in the description that goes
into depth but it's pretty much just
constructing the TBN matrices for each
normal sample and then doing the same
try blending we were doing for the
diffuse once we get that all going you
can see that everything kind of looks
right from every angle the second
technique we'll talk about is texture
splatting and this is conceptually
really simple what you're basically
doing is blending between multiple
textures using some other source of data
imagine here I've got two textures so
I've got this grass and I've got this
stone texture and I've got that
landscape from before where all the
middle will be stone
imagine I go and create a third texture
just black and white and then on the
terrain I just blend between the grass
or the rocks depending on whether the
texture is black or white this is in
essence what texture spotting is now
since the texture can have four channels
rgba I could make my blend texture even
more advanced by storing blending
weights in each Channel and then my
shader could blend between four
different textures based on that this is
all pretty much what texture splatting
is blending between a bunch of different
textures and with that in mind I'm gonna
race ahead to a much more flexible
version that I've added here complete
with source code what I do is instead of
having fixed textures in the shader I
buy in just a single texture array and
what we'll do here is we'll load a whole
bunch of textures here I've got eight
different textures that will mash
together into a single texture array and
then for each vertex will pass down four
pairs of values those will be the index
of each texture and the weight so as we
generate each vertex on the terrain will
also decide what textures to apply here
in this get texture weights function I
have a dictionary of all possible
textures and then I just apply weights
depending on the height moisture levels
whatever will use this over here in the
terrain chunk so will generate the
texture weight pairs and then this is
important so make sure you do this you
have to
get the textures the same per face and
then we passed those down into the
vertex shader the vertex shader just
passes those through to the fragment
shader and then here in the fragment
shader we can loop over the four
textures
sample them add them all together
weighted by the weight values once we've
done that we've got textures all over
the terrain and we can use as many as we
want on the terrain as long as you don't
have more than four in one spot moving
on let's talk about how to effectively
blend between textures on terrain now
normally when you blend from one texture
to another you just use a simple alpha
base blending so you get a super smooth
transition from one side to the next
this is really easy to implement but if
you want to take this just a little bit
further you want to use what's called
height based blending there's a great
article by Andrei Mishkin as' that I'll
link in the description but the gist of
the technique is that you incorporate
height into the basic alpha blending
calculation the end result being that
let's say you're blending from grass to
rocks you get grass poking out between
the rocks instead of a straight linear
blend of course to make it work with the
texture splatting that we did above we
need to modify it so I do that in
terrain blend underscore four to blend
for sample simultaneously since we need
the result to be order independent now
let's move on to the last technique here
a pseudo texture bombing technique so
first let's talk about the problem being
solved here looking at the landscape
will disable all the splatting and
triplane or stuff and here's a single
texture applied over the whole landscape
notice the distinctive pattern that
appears and it doesn't matter which
texture we choose the pattern will be
there it's really difficult to get rid
of and that's because if you look at the
UVs we've just tiled everything in every
direction it almost looks like a
checkerboard
now texture bombing is a technique from
Nvidia from like 2004 and it's basically
just a way of breaking up that
repetition they go a little nuts
sampling the texture four times but the
results are good luckily Inigo keela's
has another technique on his website
again linked below that uses a clever
trick that uses 8 virtually tiled
versions of the texture and interpolates
between 2
them so the shader code honestly I've
just lifted this straight off any ghost
site since it worked out of the box and
you can see here as I enable it the
pattern is a lot less distinct and there
we have it some techniques for texturing
our procedural world we can mix and
match between the techniques too so you
can enable just one or two here I've
just got per triplane err with a single
texture no splatting and the texture
repetition trick this would look great
as some sort of rocky world or moon for
example the point here is to know and
understand the techniques at your
disposal source code is all available on
github so fork it and go ahead and tweak
it or add to it do whatever you want
make sure you hit like and subscribe and
I'll see you next time Cheers